découvrir le domaine de trianon
autrement pour sa 11e exposition d'art
contemporain le château de versailles
ouvre des lieux inédits
le petit trianon le belvédère le
pavillon français accueillent les
personnages fictifs et les oeuvres
contemporaines d'hiroshi sugimoto la
zone du trianon n'a jamais été utilisée
avant mais maintenant c'est disponible
donc j'ai décidé d'utiliser plus
l'intimité des espaces de versailles par
rapport à la grandeur de paris depuis
2008 le château de versailles reçoit un
artiste français ou étrangers et 2018
marque le 160e anniversaire des
relations diplomatiques entre la france
et le japon
cette exposition est donc un mariage
original entre ces deux cultures
cette année c'est l'année japonisme
comme vous le savez qui consacre la
relations culturelles entre la france et
le japon ont dit qu elle met les amants
résonance et bien je crois que le
château de versailles par cette
exposition d'art contemporain illustre
tout à fait ce propos
desvres de sculpture il est aussi
question de portraits hiroshi sugimoto
aime les capter en noir et blanc
l'artiste japonais présente les ombres
des grands personnages qui ont marqué
habiter ou qui ont traversé ces lieux à
l'image de louis xiv le temps d'une
exposition le passé reprend vie c'est
une de mes pièces de sculptures ces
outils house à la porte le son ce
japonais du design à l'espace et au
jardin afin d'être ressenti dans
l'étendue de versailles
c'est un beau contraste de jouer entre
la sensibilité française et la
sensibilité japonaise de l'espace
d'autres oeuvres sont à découvrir comme
celle qui a donné son nom à l'exposition
surface de révolution l'artiste investit
les jardins du domaine de trianon
jusqu'au 17 février